all right he's got a hammer and he's
coming in like Y
Man and again don't start a million
miles away this stuff is close okay and
this is where I'm going to get I want to
make sure that I get my initial angle of
incidence so his attack is coming in
like
Yan you don't do that
r and I'm going to be inside in between
here the
knife okay so again we're close boom
right in there find it on the Y movement
make contact on the Y movement p in on
the Y movement stay
here y movement
okay y
movement don't knock it away this is
incorrect movement make sure you're
attacking you
go make sure you're
[Music]
attacking attack me attack like you're
going to
St there you
go okay let's get there but do you see
how many Corrections they got cuz you
start getting
lazy there you go like
this every time you're doing this it
should be right in that
heart every
time
don't start going around like this okay
try it again
go so we're in
close and I'm going to
have a cross with our
forearms but there's a cross on the
knife
too okay I'm not going to just have a
cross on the
forearm so getting close
knife cross on the
forearm my movement goes up a little
slower and I can blend with that but I
have to make sure I get that cross again
boom then use your adhesion to move him
over to start him off his feet so it's
not that I'm going backwards and I
pull
I move him with the two contact
points arm and face to get it moving and
now you can really see the cross with
the knife
okay
again engage we move him and there is a
cross on the knife do you see that okay
as opposed to what you guys are thinking
they're out here and you're going like
this and you're GNA grab this thing like
that no we don't want
to there's the cross on the
knife if you can as soon as you feel the
knife on your arm stick to the knife
stick to the knife on your arm
too
again okay sciss there
and here you have your disarm right
didn't so let's look at the
dis so
boom you're going to feel that it
reaches its skin cycle so you Cheeto ten
con to get him to go
around and here without doing anything
different is your this
arm your head close to your
elbow
[Music]
sh
your first movement s send him right
away send
him stay with him disarm in I'm on the
hand so that his for his forearm gets
pressed flat try to
move you see then I do my strike with
all my might you got it right through
your garden everything you
see
so move
him my
in flat because I'm on your hand I can
do it and now I can get the pin on the
forearm and through the
guard move Bove so don't be up on the
arm here I don't have the leverage pull
your elbow down you
see boom pull your elbow down not going
to happen you see and now I can turn it
under so that I can pin
it okay try it again